welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the death
knight and we have some huge leaked
footage on the Batman and the bat suit
itself every week we cover all of the
latest news on the Batman movie
same bat-time same bat-channel and today
there's a hell of a lot to unpack our
first look shows it's an outstanding
piece of kit and there's so much to talk
about as well as the additional footage
throughout this video we'll be
discussing everything the suit links to
and what the leaked footage teases for
the film there may be some spoilers here
so if you don't want anything about the
movie potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day as you don't
want to miss any of the updates that we
have without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
bat suit and the Batman leaked footage
okay so Matt Reeves just dropped the
first look at the bat suit directly on
his Twitter we have been saying for a
while that would be coming out on
Valentine's Day and this didn't
disappoint as stated throughout many of
the leaks the suit has a very handmade
feel to it and it pulls massively from
the Liebherr Meho design from his work
in the book Batman Noel and more the
footage itself has an almost daredevil
feel to it and this is a very high-tech
aspect with the featuring several panels
and more that slide all over it and give
it an armored feel primarily the fabric
looks like Teflon and it also looks like
the bat symbol may even be detachable
imagine if this was a Batarang or
something that would blow my mind
it does look bulletproof so yeah if
people are aiming for the chest then
they're likely not going to be able to
stop him we can also see on the cowl
that there is stitching and it looks
like the entire thing has been sewn
together this style is very similar to
the Batman period piece book Gotham by
Gaslight in which the character went
head-to-head with Jack the Ripper we do
know that the movie will be a murder
mystery so there's pulling from it does
make a lot of sense what's very
interesting about it as well is that the
Cape has a ridge at the top this could
also help support the character's neck
as Batman was almost hung during a comic
once and he upgraded the cow to provide
support for him so it looks like this
will give stability for the character
the piece looks extremely armored and
is well-equipped with lots of plates and
so on to provide mobility I can see this
allowing him to move stealthily whilst
also letting him put up a big fight
honestly I absolutely loved the suit and
I'm so happy that we got a first look at
it I was gonna go to bed but then I
thought I'd get up and talk about the
leaked footage then this dropped as
always making the video so yeah it's
made me so happy
I'm fanboying right now and I hope you
are too now onto the next piece of news
okay so the leaked footage comes
directly from reddit user genzou who
said that their mother noticed that they
were filming footage for the upcoming
Cape Crusader movie in London right now
this adds some validity to it as it
doesn't seem like something you would
make up especially because you know how
much Batman loves his mother shoutouts
Martha we're gonna play it so you can
see exactly what's going on and then
we're going to be breaking it down bit
by bit
I don't know what all the fuss is about
just looks like a typical day in London
and me I'm just kidding London I love
you okay so the Fuji looks like it's
been shot by a second unit and the brief
section is probably an insert that may
be used montage style to show how bad
things have gotten in terms of crime
we know that the movies production is
taking part in both Glasgow and London
with the two cities providing the
backdrop of Gotham though the footage
initially doesn't show much there's
actually a lot we can take from it and
it teases exactly what's going on in the
location in the video we see a jogger
running through broad daylight and then
he's assaulted by a gang wearing masks
and face paint the jogger is not rubber
Pattinson as many have guessed and even
if it was I'm pretty sure that Bruce
Wayne could handle himself in a fight I
used to get like 9 million combos on
Arkham Knight don't at me
the guy has a beard and a completely
different build to Pattinson so we can
separate the two instead this is likely
just an extra playing the part of a
normal citizen and this scene is purely
to show what the state of crime in
Gotham is like and why a masked
vigilante is so desperately needed as
we've said the gang beat him up in broad
daylight and smash him like you should
smash the like button so we know that
times are dire
initially it was thought on the Batman
subreddit that these people were wearing
clown masks similar to what we saw at
the end of joke air however upon closer
inspection though they are wearing face
paint it's actually just black and white
so we can stop the rumors right there
and just confirm that this won't be
connected to Joker we have a full cast
list and multiple statements from the
production team that the Joker will not
appear in the movie despite the success
of Joaquin Phoenix's portrayal does that
mean that he won't show up eventually
absolutely not
and I am actually praying that down the
line after they built a claim for both
you visions of the franchise that the
two will go head-to-head now those who
familiar with Batman we'll know that
typically these tend to be the Penguins
colors as Penguins are of course black
and white themselves and his gang tend
to stick predominantly to this this
isn't always adapted but whenever a gang
pops up donning this sort of color
scheme they are normally associated with
the character and not the Joker even
though there is what looks like a broad
smile on one the fact that they are
wearing gang colors could also indicate
that Gotham itself has been broken up
into territorial areas and each gang
inhabits a certain part it's been an
aesthetic that was seen in the
aforementioned Arkham games and is
prevalent throughout the comic books the
war of jokes and riddles is a prime
example of this as it has the Joker and
Riddler going head-to-head and basically
turning Gotham into a warzone it's also
played a massive part in the animated
series Batman Forever and much much more
throughout Batman's rich history
thematically the villains gang always
tends to dress in a certain color scheme
you've gotta love that branding we of
course know that penguin is playing a
huge part in the film with Colin Farrell
heading up the role and though he's not
the only villain it does show that there
are some areas of the city in which he
and his thugs roam I don't know if we'll
be seeing the iceburg club just yet but
the fact that the attack takes place in
daytime could highlight how people feel
about the Dark Knight if folks are
sticking to operating in the middle of
the day then it is likely that Batman
has some presence in the city and thus
they don't want to carry these things
out when the Caped Crusader could be
operating it's either that or they're so
used to the Gotham police force being
completely useless
they have no inhibitions when it comes
to attacking people in broad daylight
this also shows that the penguin has a
large number of forces and I'm really
hoping that this leads to some big big
fight scenes
the Batman warehouse seen from BBS is
still one of the greatest action scenes
put in a comic book movie in my opinion
and I really hope that we get something
similar in this outing you need to have
fights and Batman films even if they're
going in a different direction which
we'll get into in just a bit overall I'm
massively pleased with the footage and
no it's just a glimpse at it the first
look has a lot going on I really hope we
get more looks at it over the coming
weeks and there are some rumors that the
Batmobile scenes will be shooting in the
streets of Glasgow relatively shortly so
yeah fingers crossed
not too long before we see the new car
now as we've just mentioned this Batman
is going to have a completely different
feel to it
and this was backed up by the composer
of the piece earlier this week who came
out and said that the film would be
completely different to anything that
we've seen before there were several
rumors that the movie was going to be
the first real look at Batman being a
detective and the comments by the
composer had a lot more weight to this
as the character is going up against the
Riddler you will need to put his
thinking cap on and therefore the
detective skills will be required the
story is also meant to be based heavily
on the long Halloween which if you've
read then you'll know it predominantly
is a murder mystery that book sees
Batman on the trail of a killer known as
holiday who murders on well holidays in
the calendar and this will be reflected
by this aesthetic so yeah lots of good
things and before we get into the rest
of the video I just wanna let you know
we're giving away a free copy of dr.
sleep to one random subscriber all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning it's like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the updates in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February and the Celt be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part okay and finally zoe kravitz
who will be playing Selina Kyle in the
film has came forward and started
discussing it in a recent interview when
asked how she felt about Robert
Pattinson
and what it was like working with him
she said the following I've never worked
with him before but we've been together
for the last few weeks I had two camera
tests with him and now we've been
training together and rehearsing
together and he's just a delightful
person and such a wonderful thoughtful
actor I think he's perfect for the role
and it's going to be such an adventure
I'm excited to have him as my partner in
crime and to be there to support each
other because it's intense it's going to
be a long shoot and there's a lot of
pressure and I know he has my back and I
have his so yeah great comments from
Kravitz and it sounds like the two are
gonna be brawling a bit in the movie
which I'm quite looking forward to no I
don't condone hitting women I don't
condone hitting men either Amber Heard
you should have been cancelled by now
birds of prey flopping his Karma for
Warner Brothers not firing yet in my
opinion I mustered in addition to this
Kravitz has also been doing the cha-cha
and a hairstyle which will likely be the
one that she has in the film makes it
look like the classic version of the
character say classic this changes from
time to time but the short hairstyle is
often appeared on the character and it
looks like Matt Reeves is pulling
heavily from the graphic novels and
comic books to complete the look of the
character this is a look that we haven't
really seen on the big screen before and
I definitely feels more authentic all in
all this is shaping up to be a great
movie and every time I see a leak from
it I'm over the moon because it's just
so much in line with what I want from a
Batman movie it looks like they're
pulling heavily from the source material
and this has the potential to be the
most comic-book accurate film ever put
to screen anyway that's all of the big
news updates of the week so far and
thanks for checking out the video as I
mentioned we do breakdowns like this
same bat-time same bat-channel every
single week so please subscribe to be
kept up to date with everything on the
movie as it goes on
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the updates and what you want to see
in the film comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
don't forget to check out off-ball
playlists at the end that contains all
of the updates so far there's tons in
there and it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to be fully up-to-date
with the movie you want to support the
channel from its littlest ninety-nine
cents a month and please click the join
button below you get access to content
early and can suggest video topics of
breakdowns you massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made you wanna come chat
to us after the show either follow us at
Definition YT click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like it subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition that you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]